8% of adults in the US have a favorable
view of Hamas, according to Pew
Research. As disturbing as it may be
that any Americans support a terrorist
organization hellbent on exterminating
Jews, things get even worse when we
learn that 37% of Muslims in America
have a favorable view of Hamas.
Yes, more than a third of American
Muslims support a terrorist group that
declared in their 1988 charter. The
Islamic resistance movement aspires to
the realization of Allah's promise, no
matter how long that should take. The
prophet Allah bless him and grant him
salvation has said the day of judgment
will not come about until Muslims fight
the Jews, killing the Jews. When the Jew
will hide behind stones and trees, the
stones and trees will say, "Oh Muslims,
oh Abdullah, there is a Jew behind me.
Come and kill him." Only the gar,
evidently a certain kind of tree, would
not do that because it is one of the
trees of the Jews related by Albukari
and
Muslim. This hadith is now famous for
all the wrong reasons. Here it is in
Sahim Muslim. The messenger of Allah
said, "The hour will not begin until the
Muslims fight the Jews and the Muslims
will kill them. Until a Jew hides behind
a rock or a tree, and the rock or tree
will say, "Oh Muslim, oh slave of Allah,
there is a Jew behind me. Come and kill
him." Except the gar, a thorny tree, for
it is one of the trees of the Jews. So,
Hamas leaders declared in their founding
charter that they aspire to the
realization of Allah's promise, no
matter how long it should take, that
they will exterminate the Jews. But
that's not their only goal. Article 8 of
the 1988 Hamas Charter presents the
slogan of the Islamic resistance
movement. Allah is its target. The
prophet is its model. The Quran, its
constitution. Jihad is its path. And
death for the sake of Allah is the
loftiest of its
wishes. Jihad is its path. And death for
the sake of Allah is the loftiest of its
wishes. Think about the problem here.
Article 7 says that Hamas strives to
kill Jews. Article 8 says that Hamas
seeks death for the sake of Allah,
martyrdom.
So on the one hand they want to kill
Jews. On the other hand they want to die
while waging jihad for
Allah. What does Hamas seek? Death for
both sides. They want Jews dead and they
want themselves dead. A win-win for
Hamas would be death. Death. And this
mindset sadly comes straight from the
Quran. Surah 9 verse 111. Surely Allah
has bought of the believers their
persons and their property for this that
they shall have the garden. They fight
in Allah's way. So they slay and are
slain. They slay and are slain. They
kill and get killed. Death. Death. As a
rule, it's a really, really bad idea to
have a government controlled by people
who seek death for everyone, regardless
of which side they're on. And yet, 8% of
Americans and 37% of American Muslims
have a favorable view of a group that
seeks death for
everyone. I don't have such a favorable
view. Why don't I have a favorable view
of Hamas? Lots of reasons, but one of
the main reasons that I and most other
Americans don't support Hamas is that
we've all absorbed a bit of Solomon's
wisdom. We don't make the connection,
but the wisdom of Solomon has become
part of our thinking. What do I mean
here? Let's read one of the most
familiar stories in the Bible. First
Kings 3. Now two prostitutes came to the
king, King Solomon, and stood before
him. One of them said, "Pardon me, my
lord. This woman and I live in the same
house, and I had a baby while she was
there with me. The third day after my
child was born, this woman also had a
baby. We were alone. There was no one in
the house but the two of us. They were
alone, which means there were no
witnesses except the two women.
During the night, this woman's son died
because she lay on him. So she got up in
the middle of the night and took my son
from my side while I, your servant, was
asleep. She put him by her breast and
put her dead son by my breast. The next
morning, I got up to nurse my son, and
he was dead. But when I looked at him
closely in the morning light, I saw that
it wasn't the son I had born. The other
woman said, "No, the living one is my
son. The dead one is yours." But the
first one insisted, "No, the dead one is
yours. The living one is mine." And so
they argued before the king. So two
women and no other witnesses. They both
had newborn sons. One of the sons died.
And now the women are arguing about who
the living baby belongs to. This is
before DNA testing. So Solomon wants to
know who's the real mother of the child
who survived. He has to get these two
women to reveal it somehow. What does he
do? The king said, "This one says, "My
son is alive and your son is dead. While
that one says, no, your son is dead and
mine is alive." Then the king said,
"Bring me a sword." So they brought a
sword for the king. He then gave an
order. Cut the living child in two and
give half to one and half to the other.
The woman whose son was alive was deeply
moved out of love for her son and said
to the king, "Please, my lord, give her
the living baby. Don't kill him." But
the other said, "Neither I nor you shall
have him. Cut him in two."
Notice the second woman says, "Neither I
nor you shall have
him." Did she really want the
baby? No. She just didn't want the other
woman to have the baby. In other words,
her baby died and she thought to
herself, "It's not fair for my roommate
to have a baby when my baby died. So if
I can't have my baby, she shouldn't have
her baby either. The first woman, by
contrast, wanted the baby to live so
much so that she was willing to let the
other woman have him. One woman chose
life, the other chose death. And that's
exactly the information King Solomon was
looking
for. Then the king gave his ruling. Give
the living baby to the first woman. Do
not kill him. She is his mother. When
all Israel heard the verdict the king
had given, they held the king in awe
because they saw that he had wisdom from
God to administer
justice. Wisdom from God to administer
justice. According to this passage,
wisdom from God to administer justice
includes being able to look at two
opposing sides and see which side seeks
death and which side seeks life. We've
already seen that Hamas seeks death.
Death for their enemies and death for
themselves. Death.
Death. What about
Israel? This is where someone inevitably
jumps in and says, "Israel's committing
genocide." Oddly enough, it's the only
genocide in history where the population
of the victims consistently skyrockets.
So, even when Israel is supposedly
trying to wipe out a population, they
somehow bring more life. That's right.
We're not buying the genocide narrative.
We all know that if Israel wanted to
destroy the population of Gaza, they
could do it tomorrow. They don't want
to. We notice that. And here's something
else we notice. Hamas attacks men,
women, and children. They take a bunch
of hostages and then run and hide in
tunnels. They don't let Gazin civilians
hide in the tunnels. They make Gazin
civilians stay out in the
open. So the soldiers hide in tunnels
and leave women and children exposed.
Why? Because their goal is to maximize
death, especially civilian casualties.
They want as many of their own people
dead as possible. Why? They told you why
when they came up with the slogan for
their
organization. Jihad is its path and
death for the sake of Allah is the
loftiest of its
wishes. What do Israelis do when Hamas
fires rockets at Israel or launches a
terrorist attack in Israel? The houses
and apartments in Israel have safe
rooms. There are bomb shelters all over
the place. When there's an attack,
soldiers go out and fight. While
civilian men, women, and children hide
in safe rooms and shelters. The soldiers
whose job is to fight and protect go out
and fight. The people they're protecting
run and hide. It's the exact opposite of
what Hamas does. So, on one side,
soldiers face danger while civilians
take shelter. On the other side,
civilians face danger while soldiers
take shelter. If that's all I knew about
this conflict, it would be enough for me
to figure out which side seeks life and
which side seeks death. But it's not all
I know. In 2005, Israel pulled their own
people out of Gaza, including Jews who
lived
there. They gave the people of Gaza a
chance to govern themselves.
What did the people of Gaza do? They
elected a terrorist organization, Hamas,
to lead them. They wanted death. And
yet, during war, when Israel finds out
where Hamas jihadis are hiding, they
drop leaflets over the area, warning
civilians to flee. Hamas tries to keep
the civilians from fleeing because they
want civilians to die.
Israel even calls apartments and houses
to warn civilians to leave before they
attack. Very frequently the civilians
refuse to leave because many of them
also believe in the Hamas slogan, jihad
is its path and death for the sake of
Allah is the loftiest of its wishes.
Israel provides water and electricity to
Gaza to the very people who want to
annihilate them. Why? It's one of
Solomon's proverbs. He said, "You should
try to help your enemy, hoping that your
enemy will eventually feel guilty about
hating you and change his ways." Solomon
said, "If your enemy is hungry, give him
food to eat. If he is thirsty, give him
water to drink. In doing this, you will
heap burning coals on his head." That's
the guilt. And the Lord will reward you.
Do bad things happen in war? Absolutely.
And that's especially true when one side
tries to maximize civilian casualties
among its own
population. But let's be honest, because
the truth is obvious here. One side in
this conflict seeks death. Death for its
enemies and death for its own people.
The other side seeks life. Life for its
own people and even life for its
enemies.
When Hamas terrorists kill, it's because
they seek death. When IDF soldiers kill,
it's because they're trying to protect
life. Hamas absorbed an idea from
Muhammad. Surely Allah has bought of the
believers their persons and their
property for this that they shall have
the garden. They fight in Allah's way.
So they slay and are
slain. Israel absorbed an idea from
Moses. Deuteronomy 30. This day I call
the heavens and the earth as witnesses
against you, that I have set before you
life and death, blessings and curses.
Now choose life so that you and your
children may live and that you may love
the Lord your God. Listen to his voice
and hold fast to him. For the Lord is
your life, and he will give you many
years in the land he swore to give to
your fathers Abraham, Isaac, and
Jacob. Ideas matter, and we can see the
consequences of different ideas. Hamas
is like the woman who wanted the baby
dead just so the other woman wouldn't
have a baby. Hamas jihadis don't care
about the land. They've got part of the
land and they turned it into Swiss
cheese with all their terror
tunnels. If they cared about the land,
they would have a Mediterranean paradise
right now. Instead, they turned the land
into a terror factory. Everything is
about death. They're not fighting
because they care about the land.
They're fighting because they don't want
Jews to have any land.
Israel is like the woman who said,
"Don't kill the baby. Give the baby to
her." It's a completely different
situation because a piece of land,
unlike a newborn baby, can be divided
up. Even though there are Jews who would
love to have Gaza and the West Bank as
part of one big Israel, they've
repeatedly offered a two-state solution,
which was rejected every single time by
Palestinian leaders.
There are Jews who would love to not
have to worry about endless rocket
attacks and endless terrorist attacks,
but they keep accepting ceasefires
because completely destroying the
terrorists would require killing a lot
more civilians since the terrorists keep
hiding behind
civilians. There are Jews who would love
to have a temple where the Dome of the
Rock stands. Israel could tear down the
dome and start construction on the
temple tomorrow, but they
don't. They're willing to let Muslims
control the holiest sight in Judaism
just to try to keep the peace. A win-win
for Israel would be life, life, life for
them and life for their enemies who
finally give up trying to slaughter
them. One side seeks life, the other
side seeks death. And that's why no
matter how much the keyboard jihadis and
the protesters and the gropers and the
Nazis and the Candace Owens fans
complain, we keep supporting the side
that seeks life because we seek life,
too. Israel is composed of human beings.
Human beings make mistakes. The Israeli
government and the IDF, like all
governments and all militaries, will
sometimes do things that I disagree
with. Human beings and human governments
are not above
criticism. But at the end of the day, I
can't ignore the fact that they're
surrounded by people who constantly
choose death and that Israel keeps
choosing
life. It's also why I support Israel
against the economic jihad that's being
waged against it. I'm a content creator,
so the main thing I do when I want to
help is share my thoughts in a video.
But when it comes to the economic jihad
against Israel, the boycotts and
divestments, there's something else we
can do. It's a small thing, but a bunch
of people doing a small thing adds up to
a big thing. That's why I've been
promoting arts boxes this year. Lots of
small businesses in Israel went out of
business after the war started because
lots of small businesses in Israel are
tourism based and there was no tourism
after the war started. Artza is a
company that gathers products made by
small businesses in Israel, Jewish and
Christian businesses and some charities
and they send them to you in a box. Some
of these small businesses only survived
the past year and a half because they
could sell items to people like us
through arts. If you're not signed up to
get a quarterly Artza box, please sign
up. They're not very expensive,
especially considering what you're
getting and how many people you're
helping to make it through difficult
times. Why is this important? As I
pointed out before, jihadis are thinking
long term. Even if they know they can't
win a fight, they'll fight anyway and
use the fight to spread hostility
against their enemy and to hurt the
economy of their enemy with the goal of
weakening their enemy for a future fight
that they hope they can win. Do not let
jihadis destroy small businesses in
Israel. I just gave you one easy way to
help. Choose life. There's a link to the
arts website in the description. You can
use the promo code dizzle for a
discount.
Now, for you Americans who have a
favorable view of
Hamas, think about who you're siding
with. You're siding with a group that
openly admits they seek the deaths of
Jews and the deaths of their own people.
You're supporting an absolute death
cult. But just because you've been
stupid in the past doesn't mean you have
to be stupid now. breathe in a little of
Solomon's wisdom and help protect the
baby from the one who actually wants to
destroy the baby. And the one who
actually wants to destroy the
baby is Hamas.
[Music]